Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. G'day, welcome to The Rest Is History. The history of Australia is littered with marvels and wonders. From the sporting high points of the 1981 Ashes and the 2003 Rugby Union World Cup Final, to high culture, the career of Paul Hogan or the music of Midnight Oil. But Tom, if we were picking one point where Australian history really started, could you do better than the statue in Hyde Park, Sydney,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。澳大利亚的历史上充满了奇迹与惊叹。从1981年灰烬杯板球赛和2003年橄榄球世界杯决赛的高光时刻，到高雅艺术、保罗·霍根（Paul Hogan）的职业生涯，或是午夜油乐队（Midnight Oil）的音乐。但是，汤姆，如果我们要在澳大利亚历史真正开始的地方挑一个标志，还有什么能比悉尼海德公园的那座雕像更好呢？
of Captain Cook that bears the inscription, Discovered this Territory, 1770? What do you think of that? I think you've just given the most pommy introduction to Australian history imaginable. And if there are any Australian listeners left after that introduction, they'll be running for the outback. Yes, well, we do have quite a lot of Australian listeners. And we've had quite a lot of Australian listeners saying, are we going to do something on the history of Australia? They surely would have known we'd start with an introduction like that.
即库克船长雕像，上面刻着“1770年发现此地”？你对此怎么看？我觉得你刚才给出了你能想象到的最英国佬式的澳大利亚历史导言。如果在那段开场白之后还有任何澳大利亚听众留下来的话，他们肯定会逃向内陆荒原。好吧，我们的确有很多澳大利亚听众。而且我们有很多澳大利亚听众问，我们什么时候要做一期关于澳大利亚历史的节目？他们肯定知道我们会以这样的开场白开始。
I'm sure they did. I'm sure that's what they wanted. And I said, well, who should we get on? And the universal consensus of Australia was that we should get on our guest today, who is David Hunt, who has written three histories of Australia, all of them with the name, the word Girt in, as in Girt with you know a motor whatever so girt the unauthorized history of australia true girt and girt nation he's also a broadcaster who's made a film for history channel called aussie inventions that changed the world and he's a podcaster award winning uh podcaster uh of rum rebels and rat bags which i think david the the logo of that is is that captain cook it is it's it's it's captain cook wearing a silly british hat which is no such thing there's no such thing david i don't know what you're talking about british hats are always sensible i'm very
我确信他们知道。我确信这正是他们想要的。我说，嗯，我们该请谁来呢？澳大利亚各方一致的共识是，我们应该请今天的嘉宾大卫·亨特（David Hunt）。他写了三本澳大利亚历史书，书名中都有“Girt”（意为“环绕”）这个词，比如用你懂的机车什么的环绕，所以就有了《未授权的澳大利亚历史》（The Unauthorized History of Australia）、《真正的环绕》（True Girt）和《环绕之国》（Girt Nation）。他也是一位广播员，曾为历史频道（History Channel）制作了一部名为《改变世界的澳洲发明》（Aussie Inventions That Changed the World）的纪录片，他还是播客节目《朗姆酒、叛逆者与无赖》（Rum Rebels and Rat bags）的获奖制作人——大卫，那个节目的标志是库克船长吗？是的，就是库克船长戴着一顶滑稽的英国帽子。没有这种事，根本没有这种事，大卫，我不知道你在说什么。英国帽子总是很实用。我非常
disappointed that you did not mention the t20 2021 victory the other day as part of the great australian sporting history. I've no idea what you're talking about. Everyone knows that 2020 is a ludicrous format and the test is the ashes that matter. So, David. Yeah, yes. Captain Cook, great hero in Australia, but until recently when it's slightly changed, hasn't it? Well, look, when I went to school, and I'm going to date myself here,
失望的是，你刚才没有把前几天T20在2021年的胜利作为伟大澳大利亚体育史的一部分提出来。我不知道你在说什么。众所周知，2020赛制简直荒谬，只有测试赛也就是灰烬杯才重要。所以，大卫。是的，是的。库克船长，在澳大利亚是个大英雄，但直到最近情况才略有改变，对吧？嗯，你看，当我上学的时候——在这里我要暴露年龄了——
I remember Dennis Lilley playing vaguely as a young fellow, so I've just hit 50. When I went to school in the 1970s and 1980s, we were effectively taught as students that Captain Cook discovered Australia. And that was the conventional wisdom, and the school curricula had a very British view of Australian history. Recently, the Australian history curriculum has been far more complex and far more nuanced,
我还隐约记得丹尼斯·莉莉（Dennis Lillee）作为年轻人上场打球的情形，所以我刚刚年满50岁。当我在20世纪70和80年代上学时，我们实际上被灌输的学生观念是库克船长发现了澳大利亚。这是当时的共识，学校的课程大纲带有非常浓厚的英国视角。最近，澳大利亚的历史课程要复杂得多，也更有细微差别，
and there is an upwelling of criticism about statues of our colonial figures. We have to import debates from other countries before we actually have them here. So we have to see Americans and Brits getting angry about statues before we do the same thing. But the statue of Captain Cook in Hyde Park has discovered this territory 1770, which is regarded as an insult to the indigenous people who discovered this territory some 65,000 years ago, give or take a few millennia, and all of the various other people who landed on these fair shores pre-Cook, who wasn't even Captain Cook at the time. He was a lieutenant. The British perspective, I mean, we were always taught, if we were taught about Australia at all,
而且对于我们殖民时期人物雕像的批评声也如潮水般涌现。我们必须从其他国家引进辩论，然后才会在我们这里展开。所以我们必须看到美国人和英国人对雕像感到愤怒，然后我们才会做同样的事情。但是海德公园的库克船长雕像上写着“1770年发现此地”，这被视为对土著人民的侮辱，他们在早于库克大约65,000年前——上下差几个千禧年——就发现了这片土地，此外还有在库克之前登陆这片美丽海岸的各种其他人，而库克当时甚至还不是船长，他只是一名中尉。英国的视角，我的意思是，如果我们曾经接受过关于澳大利亚的教育的话——
if it was a sort of, you know, of page about Australia in a kind of world history textbook, it always was, you know, Captain Cook discovered... There was a Lady Bird book, wasn't there? There was a Lady Bird book of Captain Cook. There was a Lady Bird, but that was exactly what I was going to say. So that's the measure of fame in English history. Captain Cook is one of the sort of great canonical... You can try and discover Australia. Right, exactly. That's exactly it.
如果这只是某种，你知道的，世界历史教科书里关于澳大利亚的一页，它总是说，你知道的，库克船长发现了……有一本“瓢虫”少儿读物，对吧？有一本关于库克船长的“瓢虫”少儿读物。有一本“瓢虫”读物，这正是我要说的。这就是英国历史中名气的大小标准。库克船长是那种伟大的正统人物之一……你可以试着去发现澳大利亚。没错，正是如此，完全是这样。
And so Captain Cook is, you know, just give us a little portrait of him. Because he's not a kind of terrible guy, is he? Like a conquistador or something? I mean, he's a kind of admirable figure. He's a kind of great navigator. Undisputedly a great navigator.
所以库克船长，你知道的，给我们简单介绍一下他吧。因为他不是那种可怕的家伙，对吧？不像征服者什么的？我的意思是，他是一个令人钦佩的人物。他是一位伟大的航海家。毫无疑问的一位伟大航海家。
I mean, when he was picked for the Endeavour expedition to Australia, he was actually a fairly lowly warrant officer who'd served over in the Seven Years' War, posted to Canada, killed a few Frenchmen, which was regarded as good sport, but was noted for his cartography and also noted for writing a learned paper on the sun and navigation. Because he was basically self-taught, wasn't he? I mean, he was from very humble stock. He was kind of father was a farm labourer. Yeah, he was a grocer's apprentice and took to sailing fairly late in life, serving on the free lover sort of bohemian coal-carrying vessel that plied the channel and finds himself over in Canada.
我的意思是，当他被选中参加“奋进号”远征澳大利亚时，他实际上只是一个地位相当低微的准尉，曾在七年战争中服役，被派往加拿大，杀过几个法国人，这被认为是一项不错的运动，但他以精通海图绘制而闻名，也因撰写了一篇关于太阳与航海的学术论文而受到瞩目。因为他基本上是自学成才的，对吧？我的意思是，他出身非常卑微。他的父亲是个农场雇工。是的，他当过杂货铺学徒，比较晚才开始航海，曾在穿梭于海峡的自由恋爱式的波西米亚运煤船上服役，后来发现自己去了加拿大。
But look, undisputably a great navigator. But he was chosen for the Endeavour voyage because the primary purpose of it was to measure the transit of Venus across the sun in 1869. Sorry, 1769 in Tahiti. And so because he was a good cartographer, because he was an experienced amateur astronomer, the Royal Society promotes him effectively, or the Admiralty promotes him from warrant officer to lieutenant and posts him off to the other side of the world to measure this astronomical phenomena,
但看吧，毫无疑问他是一位伟大的航海家。不过他被选为“奋进号”航行的船员，是因为航行的首要目的是测量1869年——对不起，1769年在塔希提岛观测金星凌日。正因为他是一位优秀的制图师，因为他是一位有经验的业余天文学家，皇家学会——或者说海军部——将他从准尉提拔为中尉，并把他派往世界的另一端来测量这一天文现象，
to help measure longitude more effectively. They thought that if we can make this precise calculation of how long it takes Venus to track across the face of the sun, we'll be able to use that to improve our navigation techniques. And so from there, he then gets secret orders, doesn't he? And he kind of opens up his letters and it tells him to go and discover Australia. He gets secret orders that he is to sail home via New Zealand, which he circumnavigates and effectively improves on the charting of the Dutch.
以帮助更精确地测量经度。他们认为，如果我们能精确计算出金星穿过太阳表面所需的时间，就能用它来改进我们的航海技术。从那以后，他得到了秘密命令，对吧？他打开信件，上面指示他去发现澳大利亚。他得到了一份秘密命令，要求他经由新西兰航行回国，他环游了新西兰，实际上改进了荷兰人的海图测绘。
But also people are interested in searching for Terra Australis. This is the great mythical counterweight continent that was meant to, according to Greek philosophers, stop the globe from tipping off its axis. So Aristotle comes up with the brilliant idea once Pythagoras says, well, hey, the world's a globe. Aristotle says, well, we've got a lot of land up here where we are. There must be some down south. And so for much of the sort of 1400s, 1500s, 1600s, 1700s, there was a desire amongst some of the European powers to find this great southern land. And certainly after exploring New Zealand, he decides that he will sail home by the eastern coast of New Holland,
但同时人们也有兴趣寻找南方大陆（Terra Australis）。根据古希腊哲事家的说法，这是那个伟大的神话般的平衡大陆，本应用来阻止地球从地轴上倾斜。因此，亚里士多德在毕达哥拉斯说“嘿，世界是个球体”之后，提出了一个绝妙的想法，亚里士多德说，好吧，我们在北半球这里有这么多土地，南半球肯定也有一些。因此，在1400年代、1500年代、1600年代、1700年代的大部分时间里，一些欧洲列强都渴望找到这片伟大的南方土地。当然，在探索完新西兰后，他决定沿着新荷兰的东海岸航行回国，
as Australia was known. So it was obvious that he didn't discover Australia because he says, I'm going to go there in my butt. And in 1770, and this is one of the great stories of Australian history. The Cook's Landing Place at Botany Bay honours him for landing there on the 28th of April 1770, even though he doesn't arrive there until the following afternoon. And this date has not been corrected on the official monument for 151 years. But, David, in Britain, we find Australian days really confusing. I can never remember whether you have a head or –
正如当时澳大利亚被称为的那样。所以很明显他并没有“发现”澳大利亚，因为他说：“我要乘船去那里。”在1770年——这是澳大利亚历史上的伟大故事之一。植物湾的库克登陆地（Cook's Landing Place）为了纪念他在1770年4月28日登陆那里而向他致敬，尽管他直到第二天下午才到达那里。这个日期在官方纪念碑上151年来一直没有被纠正过。但是，大卫，在英国，我们觉得澳大利亚的日期真的很混乱。我永远记不住你们是先说日还是——
so that's obviously what it is. We'll put it down to British dating era. Yeah, exactly. But is it right that no European has landed at Bodney Bay, at least? Is that right? I mean, he's the first European to land there. Look, there's no evidence of any European exploration of the east coast of Australia before 1770. The French ran into the Great Barrier Reef a few years earlier and turned tail. in the Australian school history curricula that the Portuguese were bobbing off the coast of eastern Australia in the 1520s
所以这显然就是原因所在。我们把它归咎于英国的纪年法错误。是的，完全如此。不过，至少没有欧洲人在植物湾登陆过，这是真的吗？这准确吗？我的意思是，他是第一个在那里登陆的欧洲人吗？看，在1770年之前，没有任何证据表明欧洲人对澳大利亚东海岸进行过探索。法国人几年前撞上了大堡礁，然后就掉头回去了。
and left behind a vast mahogany ship that is buried in the dunes near the sleepy town of Warrnambool. But that theory has largely been discredited and there's no real proof. Have they found the ship? Well – What's the ship? There is believed to be some sort of vessel there in the dunes. At one stage when the sand shifted, something that looked rather like a barge rather than
但在澳大利亚学校的历史课程中有一种强烈的民间传说，即葡萄牙人在1520年代曾在澳大利亚东部海岸附近游弋，并留下了一艘巨大的桃花心木船，埋葬在瓦南布尔（Warrnambool）这个沉睡小镇附近的沙丘中。但这种理论在很大程度上已经被推翻了，而且也没有真正的证据。他们找到那艘船了吗？嗯——什么船？据信沙丘中某种船只的残骸。有一次沙子移位时，出现了一个看起来更像驳船而不是
a 16th century Portuguese or 15th century 16th century Portuguese caravel made of mahogany. When you look at the stories that appeared in the newspapers, the guy who's often credited with discovering it was an Irishman known for their tall tales in Australia. The time where he claims to have actually discovered it, he appears to have been sitting in a peat hut somewhere in Ireland. So you automatically sort of discredit the accuracy of the story.
16世纪或15世纪葡萄牙桃花心木克拉克帆船的东西。当你查看出现在报纸上的故事时，那个通常被归功于发现它的人是一个爱尔兰人，在澳大利亚，他们以爱吹牛著称。在他声称自己实际发现它的那个时间，他似乎正坐在爱尔兰某处的泥炭小屋里。所以你自然会质疑这个故事的准确性。
There were two bits, reported bits of the mahogany ship were collected by a bloke called Archibald, who was the editor of a leading Australian magazine, donated to the Australian National Library, and they've been later tested and found to be made of eucalyptus, a tree that was in a fairly short supply in Portugal in the 1500s. So let's sort of pull back a bit then. So Cook is supposed to have arrived at this date in Bosney Bay.
有两块据报道是桃花心木船的碎片被一个名叫阿奇博尔德（Archibald）的家伙收集了，他是澳大利亚一家主要杂志的编辑，后来捐赠给了澳大利亚国家图书馆，经后来的测试发现它们是由桉树制成的——这种树在1500年代的葡萄牙是非常短缺的。所以我们稍微倒回来看一下。因此，库克应该是在这个日期到达植物湾的。
There's a statue of Cook, but obviously he's not the first human being to have arrived at this date in Bosney Bay. There's a statue of Cook. But obviously, he's not the first human being to have discovered Australia. So how long have human beings been in Australia before Captain Cook? Well, we've actually got a massive question here from Rachel Everett-Gouache. I hope I've pronounced that right. How did people get there? When did they get there? How long did it take to occupy such a vast area? So there are three massive questions.
那里有一座库克雕像，但显然他并不是在这个日期到达植物湾的第一个人类。那里有一座库克雕像。但显然，他并不是发现澳大利亚的第一个人类。那么在库克船长之前，人类在澳大利亚生活了多久？嗯，我们这里其实有一个来自雷切尔·埃弗雷特-瓜什（Rachel Everett-Gouache）的宏大问题。希望我没有读错名字。人们是怎么到那里的？他们是什么时候到达的？占领这么大一片区域花了多长时间？所以这里有三个巨大的问题。
The great thing about history is, of course, it's contestable. Prehistory, for want of a better term, is even more contestable. When I was a kid, we were taught that Aboriginal people had been on the continent for about 10,000 years. The date that is commonly accepted now is around 60,000 to 65,000 years. Some people push that back to 120,000 years, but there's a broad consensus of 65,000, give or take, a couple of millennia. So this is Homo sapiens coming out of Africa, crossing Asia, going down, across the islands. Of course, Aboriginal people, some Aboriginal people maintain
历史的伟大之处当然在于它是可以辩论的。史前史——如果借用这个更好的词的话——就更具争议性了。当我还是个孩子的时候，我们被教导说原住民在这个大陆上生活了大约1万年。现在普遍接受的日期大约是6万到6万5千年。有些人把这个时间推前到12万年，但普遍的共识是6万5千年，上下误差几千年。所以这就是智人走出非洲，穿过亚洲，南下，穿过各个岛屿。当然，原住民，一些原住民坚称
that they were created here and they've always been here, but the scientific evidence would support the out-of-Africa thesis that they effectively island-ped um from uh uh sunda as sort of southeast asia was known to sell the continental landmass of sahoo which which took in australia and new guinea sea levels were between 70 and 140 40 meters lower than they are now is that because all the water's locked up in ice is this this during the Ice Ages? Yeah, during one of the Ice Ages. So you could sort of walk around New Guinea, Australia,
他们是在这里被创造的，他们一直都在这里，但科学证据将支持“出非洲”的论点，即他们实际上是通过岛屿跳跃——从当时被称为巽他大陆（Sunda）的东南亚，到达了包含澳大利亚和新几内亚的萨胡尔（Sahul）大陆。当时的海平面比现在低70到140米，这是因为所有的水都被冰封住了吗？这是在冰河时代吗？是的，在冰河时代期间。所以你可以步行环游新几内亚，澳大利亚和
Tasmania were part of one landmass. They were obviously a seafaring people because to get across the Sunda Strait and to get across the Wallace Line that separates Bali and Lombok, it's a deep ocean trench that the big scary animals of Asia had never been able to get across. So no tigers in Lombok. And so when the first Australians would have crossed that line, they would have suddenly found this sort of land where there were no large prey animals intent on eating them, but there were lots of animals that had never seen humans before
塔斯马尼亚曾是同一陆地的一部分。他们显然是航海民族，因为要穿过巽他海峡，并穿过分隔巴厘岛和龙目岛的华莱士线（Wallace Line）——这是一条亚洲大型可怕动物从未能跨越的深海海沟。所以龙目岛没有老虎。因此，当第一批澳大利亚人跨越这条线时，他们会突然发现这样一片土地：那里没有一心想吃掉他们的庞大猎物，但有很多从未见过人类的动物，
that basically sat there and you could club them over their head and have a jolly good meal. So that was probably the first experience of Australia around about 65,000 years ago. But in Australia then, I mean, there are extraordinary animals. So there is the marsupial lion. Yes, yes, yes. Supposedly kind of lurks in trees.
它们基本上就坐在那里，你可以用棍棒敲它们的脑袋，然后美美地饱餐一顿。所以这可能是大约65,000年前人类对澳大利亚的第一印象。但在当时的澳大利亚，我的意思是，这里有非凡的动物。所以有有袋狮。是的，yes，yes。据说潜伏在树上。
Fibrocolio carnifex. Yes. I went to Adelaide and saw a skeleton of it in the museum there, and it looked very menacing, and you wouldn't want to have it drop out on top of you from a tree. No, they got up to about 130 kilos. They're believed to be ambush predators. Their musculature suggests that they perhaps weren't great runners,
肉食有袋狮（Thylacoleo carnifex）。是的。我去阿德莱德时在当地的博物馆里看到了它的骨骼，它看起来非常具有威胁性，你绝对不想让它从树上掉落砸到你头上。没有，它们体重可达130公斤左右。人们认为它们是伏击型掠食者。它们的肌肉结构表明它们可能不擅长奔跑，
but they're effectively the size of a panther or a leopard that would leap out and take a nibble of you. Dennis, liliesque predator to have jumping on you. We've had lots of questions about this, haven't we? So the Kanzuk kid and others have asked about, I mean, all kinds of things, land crocodiles, giant koalas, giant kangaroos. Are these things real? Do they really exist? Yeah, so look, megafauna, as they're known, giant kangaroos. Are these things real? Do they really exist?
但它们实际上有豹子或美洲豹那么大，会跳出来咬你一口。这是一种像丹尼斯·莉莉一样的掠食者，会跳到你身上。我们有很多关于这方面的问题，对吧？所以“库克小子”（Kanzuk kid）和其他人问过，我的意思是，各种各样的事情，陆地鳄鱼，巨型考拉，巨型袋鼠。这些东西是真的吗？它们真的存在吗？是的，所以你看，巨型动物群（megafauna），正如它们所知，巨型袋鼠。这些东西是真的吗？它们真的存在吗？
Yeah, so look, megafauna, as they're known, which is Latin for really big animal. Yeah, look, Australia had its own megafauna. The land crocodile, the quincana, is one of my favourites. It grows up to maybe seven metres in length. It's got – its legs are underneath it for walking on land rather than at its sides for paddling. And fossils have been found in areas near no known watercourses. So, you know, you British tourists are afraid of all sorts of animals
是的，所以你看，巨型动物群（megafauna），在拉丁语中是“非常大的动物”的意思。是的，看，澳大利亚有它自己的巨型动物群。陆地鳄鱼，奎卡纳鳄（Quinkana），是我的最爱之一。它的体长可达七米左右。它的腿是在身体下方以便在陆地上行走，而不是在两侧用于划水。在没有已知水道的地区发现了化石。所以，你知道的，你们英国游客害怕各种各样的动物
in Australia, particularly those in our waterways. This was actually one that you could be scared of on land as well. I didn't know the way you said you began that sentence with such contempt, you British tourists. Well, it's always the first question we're asked is about our animals. But drone koalas, look, there was a koala only about a third larger than our current koala. We in Australia have legends of the drop bear,
在澳大利亚，特别是那些在我们水道里的动物。这其实是一种你在陆地上也需要感到害怕的动物。我不知道你开始这句话时带着的那种蔑视的语气，你们英国游客。好吧，我们被问到的第一个问题总是关于我们的动物。但是巨型考拉，看，曾有一种考拉比我们现在的考拉大约三分之一。我们在澳大利亚有关于“掉落熊”（drop bear）的传说，
basically designed to frighten tourists of giant koalas that drop from the trees and savage you. No evidence of the drop bear. My favourite, there was, of course, the diprotodon, which was the largest. Yes, the giant wombat. Giant wombat. Well, yeah. It's sort of a rhinoceros-sized wombat-like creature.
基本上是为了吓唬游客，说有巨型考拉会从树上掉下来猛烈攻击你。没有证据表明存在“掉落熊”。我最喜欢的，当然是双门齿兽（Diprotodon），它是最大的。是的，巨型袋熊。巨型袋熊。嗯，是的。它是一种犀牛大小的类似袋熊的生物。
And one of the things about Australia is that its land is incredibly arid, limited nutrients in plants, and lots of the large marsupials here, pouched animals, to conserve energy, their brain pan or their brain devolved. So you're saying they're thick. They were remarkably thick. The koala today, its brain has shriveled so that it effectively
澳大利亚的特点之一是其土地极其干旱，植物中的营养成分有限，这里许多大型的有袋动物——即有育儿袋的动物——为了保存能量，它们的脑腔或大脑退化了。所以你是说它们很笨。它们笨得惊人。今天的考拉，它的大脑已经萎缩，以至于它基本上
gets concussion every time it turns its head. Oh, that's adorable. Because it's trying to save energy. But look, it's too whacked out on gum leaves to really notice. But the diprotodon, again, large skull, large sinuses, small brain. So old koalas would be gutted by the degeneracy of their descendants. Is that what you're saying? Well, that's right. We Australians have obviously evolved smaller brains in the last 200 years.
每次转头都会脑震荡。哦，太可爱了。因为它在试图节省能量。但看，它对桉树叶已经嗨到麻木了，根本注意不到。但双门齿兽，同样是拥有大头、大鼻窦、小大脑。所以老考拉会被它们的后代的退化气得够呛？你是这个意思吗？嗯，没错。我们澳大利亚人在过去200年里显然进化出了更小的大脑。
Just on Diprotodon, which is this enormous wombat. Wombats, famously, their poos are square. Did Diprotodon do kind of like, do we know? Did he do enormous square-shaped turds? There is actually a field of study from which you can date when the megafauna may have died out, which is looking at the fungus that could be found in the poos of herbivorous animals in Australia.
就在双门齿兽——这种巨大的袋熊身上。众所周知，袋熊的粪便形状是方的。双门齿兽拉的粪便——我们知道吗？它拉的是不是那种巨大的方形粪便？其实有一个研究领域可以通过它来判断巨型动物群可能是何时灭绝的，那就是研究澳大利亚食草动物粪便中可以发现的真菌。
There's no suggestion that the diprotodon had a square arsehole. Oh, that's a shame. That's a shame. Look, I mean, my favourite example of the megafauna is known by archaeologists and naturalists affectionately as the demon duck of doom. Wow. So, Bullacus planae, which is basically a quarter-tonne, eight-foot-tall carnivorous kick-ass duck. So it probably had died out before the first Australian humans appeared.
没有任何迹象表明双门齿兽长着方形的肛门。哦，那太遗憾了。那太遗憾了。看，我的意思是，我最喜欢的巨型动物群的例子，被考古学家和自然学家亲切地称为“末日恶魔鸭”（demon duck of doom）。哇。所以，平原牛巨鸭（Bullactus planae），基本上是一只重达四分之一吨、八英尺高的食肉暴力鸭。所以它可能在第一批澳大利亚人类出现之前就已经灭绝了。
Can I just ask specifically about humans arriving and the megafauna? Yeah. The megafauna is no longer around. Humans have arrived. Is there a link? Basically, are humans killing out out wiping out all these giant animals and it's interesting this is one of the sort of politically uh contested i can guess it is would be because because australian australian history because the idea is that that aboriginal australians
我能具体问一下人类到达与巨型动物群的关系吗？可以。巨型动物群已经不复存在了。人类已经到达。这之间有联系吗？基本上，是人类杀死了、消灭了所有这些巨大的动物吗？有趣的是，这是那种在政治上有争议的话题——我能猜到会的——因为，因为澳大利亚的历史，因为这种观点认为，澳大利亚原住民
have cared for the land in a way that that's why europeans haven't so rather than rather than eating all the big animals and birds many of the forests. Yeah. Look, the jury remains out. There's no doubt that some of the megafauna co-existed with humans for a period of time. The length of time is contested. There appears to have been a significant megafaunal die-off about 40,000 to 44,000 years ago. Tim Flannery, who wrote a wonderful book called The Future Eaters, has the Blitzkrieg
一直以一种保护土地的方式关怀着它，这也是为什么欧洲人没有这样做，而不是吃掉所有的大型动物和鸟类以及许多森林。是的。看，陪审团目前还没有定论。毫无疑问，一些巨型动物群与人类共存了一段时间。共存的时间长短是有争议的。大约在4万到4.4万年前，似乎发生过一次大规模的巨型动物群消亡事件。蒂姆·弗兰纳里（Tim Flannery）写过一本名为《食未来者》（The Future Eaters）的精彩书籍，他提出了巨型动物群灭绝的“闪击战”
theory of megafaunal extinction, which is essentially when humans arrived in Australia, there were all these big animals with small brains that sat there and let you put them on their head and said, eat me. And so, you know, people had really big barbecues for a very long time. And once the megafauna died out, there was a move to the hunting theory that aboriginal people fundamentally changed the australian landscape to to hunt for smaller food prey the alternative theory is that climate change played a significant impact um the the growing erudification of the continent as the result of the the the ice age is is there a sense in which this argument is driven by politics or would that be an overly reductive way of framing it?
理论，其核心本质是：当人类到达澳大利亚时，这里到处都是大脑很小的大型动物，它们就坐在那里，让你摸它们的头，还说着“吃我吧”。所以，你知道的，人们开了很长时间的超级烧烤派对。而一旦巨型动物群灭绝，人们就转向了狩猎理论，即原住民从根本上改变了澳大利亚的景观，以寻找较小的猎物。另一种理论是，气候变化产生了重大影响，即作为冰河时代结果的大陆日益干旱化。这种争论在某种程度上是由政治驱动的吗？或者说，这样构架问题会不会显得过于简单化了？
No, look, it's a debate that moves backwards and forwards. And look, there were probably pockets of megafauna that survived until relatively recent times. There's the Bradshaw paintings or the Gweon Gweon paintings in Arnhem Land in the north of Australia, which are probably dated about 17,500 years ago. There's a couple of them that feature what appears to be a marsupial lion. Yeah, it kind of looks like Tigger, doesn't it, from Winnie the Pooh? It does. Or the tiger from Calvin and Hobbes.
不，你看，这是一场反复拉锯的辩论。而且你看，可能还存在一些巨型动物群的避难所，一直存活到相对较近的时期。在澳大利亚北部的阿姆恩兰（Arnhem Land），有布拉德肖岩画（Bradshaw paintings）或格溫格溫岩画（Gweon Gweon paintings），其年代大约可追溯到17,500年前。其中有几幅描绘了看起来像有袋狮的东西。是的，它看起来有点像小熊维尼里的跳跳虎，对吧？确实如此。或者像《卡尔文和霍布斯》里的那只老虎。
Yes, that's right. A striped dog-like creature that could be a thylacine, the Tasmanian tiger, which the last ones died out in Australia in the 1930s down in Tasmania. Or did they? Or did they? Yes, yes. Oh, yes.
是的，没错。一种带条纹的狗类生物，可能是袋狼（thylacine），也就是塔斯马尼亚虎，最后一批袋狼于20世纪30年代在塔斯马尼亚灭绝了。或者真的是这样吗？或者真是这样吗？是的，是的。哦，是的。
There's a whole episode in that yeah we must get down let's get back to the let's get back to the the aborigines so yeah you're talking you that all the theories about um uh what they did i mean those obviously rest on some sense of what their culture might have been so when we're talking about the first australians let's say let's say 50 000 40 000 years ago are we basinging that on specific archaeological evidence or are people extrapolating back from what they know of Aboriginal society in the 18th century or whenever? A number of different factors.
这其中包含着一整集的素材，是的，我们必须深入探讨一下——让我们回到原住民的话题上来。所以，你刚才谈到了关于他们行为的所有理论，这些理论显然建立在对他们文化可能是什么样的一种理解之上。因此，当我们谈论第一批澳大利亚人时，比如说，5万年前、4万年前，我们是基于具体的考古证据，还是人们根据18世纪或其他时期对原住民社会的了解进行倒推呢？是由许多不同的因素共同决定的。
I mean, radiocarbon dating, sort of you can get 40,000, 50,000 years back before it stops being effective. Mungo Man is the sort of oldest body of an Aboriginal person that dates to about 40,000 BP. It's also the earliest example in the world that's known of ritual burial, where the body is buried with ochre paint sprinkled upon it. Right. You've got earlier dating of stone implements through sort of luminescent technology,
我的意思是，放射性碳测年法，你可以追溯到4万年、5万年前，然后它就会失去效用。蒙哥人（Mungo Man）是迄今发现的最古老的澳大利亚原住民遗体，年代大约在距今4万年前。这也是世界上已知的最早的仪式性埋葬案例，遗体下葬时洒上了赭石颜料。对的。通过发光测年技术，你可以对石器进行更早的年代测定，
which can calculate how old something is by when it was sort of heated in a fire, as some early stone tools were. And you've got some genetic dating which suggests somewhere between 60 and 75,000 years ago as a timeline that sort of genetically fits. But beyond those things, can we say anything more sort of, I mean, obviously we know that there were people there, but can we say anything about the kind of society that they had
该技术可以通过计算某个东西在火中被加热的时间来推算其年龄——早期的一些石器就是这样制作的。此外，还有一些基因测年数据表明，6万到7.5万年前之间的某个时间线在基因上是吻合的。但除了这些东西之外，我们还能说出更多——我的意思是，显然我们知道那里有人，但我们能描述一下他们拥有的社会类型，
or their religion or their family structures or any of those kinds of things? Well, we certainly know in recent millennia what those things were like. I mean, you have over 250 languages, so you have a period of time for dispersal. You have most of Australia with one language group with different languages within that group and more completely different languages in the north, which may coincide with an infusion of Indian settlement several thousand years ago. And so, David, is it thought that the original wave of arrival of humans, say, 60,000 years ago, is that basically the group from which all the Aboriginal peoples in Australia descend, or are there waves of people coming? What's the thinking on that? Yeah, there's the single wave theory and the multi-wave theory.
或者他们的宗教、家庭结构，或者诸如此类的任何事情吗?嗯，我们当然知道最近几千年这些事情是什么样的。我的意思是，你们有250多种语言，所以你们有一个漫长的传播时期。澳大利亚的大部分地区共享一个语言群，该群内部有不同的语言，而北部则有更多完全不同的语言，这可能与几千年前印度定居者的流入相吻合。那么，大卫，人们是否认为人类最初的到达浪潮，比如说6万年前，基本上就是所有澳大利亚原住民繁衍后代的那个群体，还是说有几波人来到这里？对此目前的看法是什么？是的，存在“单次浪潮理论”和“多次浪潮理论”。
And the single wave theory says that with the genetic diversity that you have in Australia, you would have had to have had about between 1,000 and 3,000 people come across about 65,000 years ago to have the genetic diversity that you have with the first Australians at the time of first contact. We know that the Lapita people, the sort of proto-Polynesian seafarers, probably stopped off and gave us the dingo sort of 4,000 years ago. There are suggestions of some Indian genetic admixture in the north of Australia again around that 5,000-year mark. So the multi-wave theory is that there were, if you can have one group of people coming over, why can't you have two, three, four, five or more? That is, there is some political and cultural arguments associated with that which suggests that people who are Aboriginal today were perhaps invaded by other people rather than having been there all the time and the first owners. So it's contested.
“单次浪潮理论”认为，鉴于澳大利亚现有的遗传多样性，大约在65,000年前，必须有大约1,000到3,000人跨海而来，才能拥有第一批澳大利亚人在首次接触时所具备的遗传多样性。我们知道，拉皮塔人（Lapita people）——也就是原始波利尼西亚航海家——大约在4,000年前可能在此停留并给我们带来了澳洲野犬。有迹象表明，大约在5,000年前的那个时间节点，澳大利亚北部再次出现了印度的基因混合。因此，“多次浪潮理论”认为，既然你可以有一群人渡海过来，为什么不能有两群、三群、四群、五群甚至更多呢？也就是说，这其中存在一些政治和文化的争论，暗示如今的原住民可能是被其他人侵略的，而不是一直呆在那里并作为第一主人。所以这是有争议的。
So there's a question here from the Burning Archive. It is sometimes said these days that Aboriginal culture is the oldest continuous culture in the world. Is this true? How could we know? How could we know is a very good question. Yeah. What you can say is that some of the Aboriginal Dreamtime stories suggest a continual culture and oral tradition that is many, many millennia old. There are stories of creatures that sound like megafauna in some of the Aboriginal Dreamtime stories. Is that the bunyip? Yeah, the bunyip, which is meant to be a grumpy creature that inhabits waterholes that we Australians call billabongs,
这里有一个来自“燃烧档案馆”（Burning Archive）的问题。如今有时有人说，原住民文化是世界上最古老的连续文化。这是真的吗？我们怎么能知道呢？“我们怎么能知道”是一个非常好的问题。是的。你可以说的是，一些原住民的“幻梦期”（Dreamtime）故事表明了一种延续许多许多千年的文化和口头传统。有些故事里描述的生物听起来很像原住民“幻梦期”故事中的巨型动物群。那是“尤尼普”（bunyip）吗？是的，“尤尼普”，传说中是一种脾气暴躁的生物，栖息在我们澳大利亚人称为“比拉邦”（billabongs）的水潭里，
may trace its origins to the diprotodons that used to sort of wade in sort of marshland. There are also a range of stories of very large animals that gathered and gathered in the trees, perhaps which is where the giant koala theory comes from, that may trace back to a megafaunal-type creature. But also there are particular stories in very arid parts of Australia of a landscape that was radically different, much more fertile, and stories that really seem to be tracing back for people who've been in the same place for a while
它的起源可能会追溯到过去在沼泽地里蹚水的双门齿兽。这里还有一系列关于巨型动物的传说，它们聚集在树林里，这也许就是巨型考拉理论的来源，这些传说可能会追溯到某种巨型动物群类的生物。此外，在澳大利亚极其干旱的地区，还有一些特定故事描述了一个截然不同、肥沃得多的景观，这些故事似乎确实可以追溯到那些在同一个地方生活了一段时间、经历过截然不同气候的人们。
to quite a different climate. Before we go, we have to have a break in a minute or two, but just before we do that, the Dreamtime stories, can you tell us a little bit about what they are and how we know about them and how we know that they are kind of authentic or continuous rather than, you know, so much folklore tends to be invented or sort of elaborated upon and, of course, changes over time. So, the Dreamtime stories, tell us a little bit more about them. Well, I mean, you have the Aboriginal people had an oral tradition. They didn't have writing. So you have an oral system of communication through the generations. You have songlines, which are effectively cultural songs that are passed on through the generations,
在我们结束前——我们在一两分钟内必须休息一下——但在那之前，“幻梦期”的故事，你能给我们讲讲它们是什么、我们是如何了解它们的、以及我们怎么知道它们是真实可信的或连续的，而不是像许多民间传说那样往往是凭空捏造的或精心雕琢的，当然，它们随着时间推移也会发生变化。所以，关于“幻梦期”的故事，请给我们多讲讲。嗯，我的意思是，澳大利亚原住民拥有口头传统。他们没有文字。所以他们通过代代相传的口头系统进行交流。你们有“歌路”（songlines），它们实际上是代代相传的文化歌曲，
describing the landscape in some detail and particular geographical features that form a form of mnemonic device to navigate around your bit of the continent. But the idea of the Dreamtime, Aboriginal history is very different from a Western history where we focus on progress. Aboriginal cultures focused on continuity and stability. And the Dreamtime stories were, if you like, a way of codifying rules and laws.
详细描述了地貌和特定的地理特征，构成了一种记忆辅助工具，帮助你在大陆的各个角落穿行。但“幻梦期”的概念——澳大利亚的历史与我们关注进步的西方历史非常不同。原住民文化侧重于连续性和稳定性。“幻梦期”的故事，如果你愿意的话，是一种将规则和法律编纂成册的方式。
They had supernatural elements. We know that modern Aboriginal people had sort of animist religious spiritual beliefs, that their ancestors inhabited rocks and trees of significance. And so you have this complex series of laws, cultural traditions, stories about who you can marry and who you can't marry. and it was beautifully summed up by an Australian anthropologist, Bill Stanner, who described the sort of dream time as timeless, described it as every when. So it's this fusing of spirituality with the past, present, and the future into sort of a series of stories as to how life is to be lived
它们具有超自然元素。我们知道现代原住民拥有某种万物有灵的宗教精神信仰，他们的祖先栖息在具有重要意义的岩石和树木中。因此，你拥有了一系列复杂的法律、文化传统、关于你可以和谁结婚、不可以和谁结婚的故事。澳大利亚人类学家比尔·斯坦纳（Bill Stanner）对这一点作了精辟的总结，他将“幻梦期”描述为永恒的，描述为“无时不在”（every when）。因此，这是将灵性与过去、现在和未来融为一体的一系列故事，讲述了应该如何生活，
and life is to be regulated. And when were they written down by non-Aboriginals? So were they recorded in the 19th century or how does that work? And look, this is one of the tricky bits. Often white explorers weren't terribly interested in sitting down and listening to Aboriginal stories. They were far more interested in chasing Aboriginal people off the land they were trying to put their sheep on. So certainly there are particularly Aboriginal creation myths.
以及生活应该如何受到规范。那么它们是什么时候由非原住民写下来的呢？它们是在19世纪被记录下来的，还是怎么回事？看，这是棘手的部分之一。通常白人探险家对坐下来聆听原住民的故事并不怎么感兴趣。他们对把原住民赶出他们正试图放羊的土地要感兴趣得多。所以当然，特别是原住民的创世神话，
They were collected because missionaries who were interested in spreading the word of God were trying to tap into what do you have there in terms of creation mythology. So you have many Aboriginal cultures have got a giant snake-like creator figure that is associated with water that Westerners name the Rainbow Serpent that appears throughout Australia. Down in Tasmania, the Tasmanian Aboriginal people of Bruny Island had a creator named Lala who appears to have been a giant ant. So there was some recording of these stories, but the best records you would have would be with Aboriginal people who wrote those stories down themselves in the late 19th and the early 20th century and to continue to tell those stories orally.
之所以被收集起来，是因为热衷于传播上帝话语的传教士们正试图探究你们在创世神话方面有什么内容。因此，许多原住民文化都有一个与水相关的巨蛇般的创作者形象，西方人将其命名为“彩虹蛇”（Rainbow Serpent），它在全澳大利亚各地都有出现。在塔斯马尼亚，布鲁尼岛（Bruny Island）的塔斯马尼亚原住民有一个名叫拉拉（Lala）的造物主，他似乎是一只巨型蚂蚁。因此，这些故事确实有一些记录，但你所能拥有的最好记录，是那些在19世纪末和20世纪初亲自将这些故事写下来的原住民，他们继续以口头方式讲述这些故事。
And just one last question before we go to a break. Do you think – did Aboriginal peoples in Australia have a sense of themselves as belonging to kind of the same group of people or do they have no sense of that at all? Is that a kind of a colonial imposition? So that's – look, the entire notion of Aboriginality is a colonial construct. I mean, Australia is, you know, the size of Western Europe plus some. It's like saying, you know, do the Poles and the Cornish regard each other as similar.
在进入休息前的最后一个问题。你认为——澳大利亚原住民是否觉得自己属于同一群人，或者他们完全没有这种意识？这是一种殖民强加的概念吗？所以你看——看，原住民身份（Aboriginality）的整个概念就是一个殖民建构。我的意思是，澳大利亚的面积，你知道的，相当于西欧再加上一些。这就好比在问，波兰人和康沃尔人是否认为彼此是一样的。
Yeah. You have over 250 language groups. Within those language groups, you have up to 50 clans, as low as just a handful of clans. So these people did not see each other as part of the same people. That being said, there was trade and communication across the continent. You have shells from northern Queensland appearing in western Australia where they were passed on as trade goods. So you have communication and trade occurring over large distances,
是的。你们有250多种语言群。在这些语言群内部，有多达50个氏族，少则只有寥寥几个氏族。所以这些人并不认为彼此是同一群人。话虽如此，整个大陆之间确实存在贸易和交流。昆士兰州北部的贝壳出现在西澳大利亚州，它们作为贸易商品被传递下去。因此，跨越大距离的交流和贸易是存在的，
but there was certainly not the belief we are all Aboriginal people. All right. Well, I think we should go for a break now. And when we come back, perhaps we could look at the process by which Europeans and perhaps Chinese discovered Australia. Oh, good. I like that bit. We'll be back in a minute.
但绝没有“我们都是原住民”这种信念。好了，我想我们现在应该去休息一下了。等我们回来时，也许我们可以看看欧洲人——甚至可能是中国人——发现澳大利亚的过程。哦，太好了。我喜欢那部分。我们一分钟后回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Australia, and in particular, we've been talking about Australia before the arrival of the first Europeans, or indeed the first British.
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在谈论澳大利亚，特别是我们一直在讨论第一批欧洲人或英国人到达之前的澳大利亚。
So, David, the first outsiders, as in non-Aboriginal peoples, to arrive in Australia. Now, in Britain, we were always brought up to think that this is Captain Cook, followed by boatloads of convicts but we've got a question from for example nova sleuth one of our listeners who asks about contact between indonesians and malayans or the people who lived in what are now indonesia and malaya um so are they arriving in Australia? And if so, why don't they settle it and colonize it? So there's evidence of the Makassans from the island of Sulawesi, which is modern-day Indonesia,
所以，大卫，第一批外来者——也就是非原住民——到达澳大利亚。在英国，我们从小受到的教育一直认为，这是库克船长，后面跟着一船船的罪犯。但我们有一个问题，例如来自诺瓦·斯露（Nova Sleuth）——我们的一位听众——的问题，她询问了印度尼西亚人与马来人之间，或者生活在现在的印度尼西亚和马来西亚的人们之间的接触，嗯，他们是到达澳大利亚了吗？如果是这样，他们为什么不进行定居和殖民呢？有证据表明，来自苏拉威西岛（现代印度尼西亚的一部分）的望加锡人（Makassans），
fishermen who the precise date is uncertain. It's certainly the early 1600s, probably in the 1500s, and they were coming to the northern shores of Australia to fish for trepang, sea cucumber, which was prized in China as an aphrodisiac. So that contact was, Australia was effectively an Asian sex shop as people are coming here to get this very ugly creature. It's basically a black sausage that sits in shallow coastal waters and aspires to nothing more than not ending up in a Beijing sex shop. And the Macassans –
这些渔民的确切日期并不确定。这肯定是在1600年代初期，可能在1500年代，他们来到澳大利亚北部海岸捕捞海参（trepang，即海黄瓜），海参在中国被视为主催情剂而备受推崇。因此这种接触意味着，澳大利亚实际上是一个亚洲的成人用品商店，人们来到这里获取这种非常丑陋的生物。它基本上是一根黑色的香肠，栖息在浅海沿岸水域，其最高理想就是不落入北京的成人用品商店。而望加锡人——
What a life. That's it. The Macassans came here and they form close cultural relations with the Yongle people in Arnhem Land and actually effectively buy their labor for this industry. You have probably about a thousand Macassans coming here each season. They stay for months. They build these sort of demountable factories where they process the trepang, the sea cucumber. It's boiled, it's dried, it's buried in the sand for a few weeks,
多好的一生啊。就是这样。望加锡人来到这里，与阿姆恩兰的永盖（Yolngu）人建立了紧密的文化关系，并实际上为这个行业买断了他们的劳动力。每个季节大约有一千名望加锡人来到这里。他们逗留数月。他们建造这种可拆卸的工厂，在那里加工海参——这种海参会被煮沸、晒干、埋在沙里几周、
it's dug up, it's boiled, it's packaged, and it's shipped off. And they traded glass, cloth, metal implements, alcohol, and there was language exchange as well. So when the first Europeans came to this part of Australia, when they appeared, the Aboriginal, the Yongle knew of them and they called them, ah, Belanda, which was Hollander that they'd picked up from the Macassan people. So they had an idea that there were Europeans out there. But yeah, that's the, other than the sort of Lapita
挖出来、煮沸、打包，然后运走。他们用玻璃、布料、金属器具、酒进行交易，并且还进行了语言交流。因此，当第一批欧洲人来到澳大利亚这部分地区时，当他们出现时，原住民永盖人认出了他们，并称他们为“巴兰达”（Belanda），这是他们从望加锡人那里学来的对“荷兰人”（Hollander）的称呼。所以他们知道外面有欧洲人。但这就是，除了拉皮塔人之外
proto-Polynesians who arrived about 4,000 years ago and dropped off the dingo, they are the first really established contacts. Why don't people come in greater numbers? Why don't – given the population in Southeast Asia and so on and given that they are moving around in boats, they're seafaring peoples, why don't more people come to Australia? So, look, there is some Lapita DNA in some of the northern Torres Strait Islands and on the southern coast of New Guinea, predominantly Melanesian,
大约在4,000年前抵达并带来了澳洲野犬的原波 Polynesian 人，是第一批真正确立联系的人。为什么没有更多的人来呢？鉴于东南亚的人口等等，而且考虑到他们是乘船四处游历的航海民族，为什么没有更多的人来澳大利亚呢？所以，你看，在托雷斯海峡北部的一些岛屿和新几内亚南海岸有一些拉皮塔人的DNA，主要属于美拉尼西亚人，
but some Polynesian influence as well. I think the answer is nobody really knows. There may have been, if you're coming in just a handful of boats and you encounter stiff resistance from some people who don't want you to stop there, as occurred in the Andaman Islands for centuries, if you run into some territorial people who drive you off, maybe you don't want to stay. But there certainly was trade with the dingo, and kangaroo fleas then appear to have got on dingoes
但也有一点波利尼西亚的影响。我认为答案是没人真正知道。可能存在这种情况：如果你只乘几艘船来，却遇到了某些不想让你在那儿停留的人的强力抵抗——正如安达曼群岛几个世纪以来所发生的那样，如果你碰上一群把你们赶走的领地土著，也许你就不想留下来了。但当时肯定存在与澳洲野犬相关的贸易，而袋鼠跳蚤后来似乎也跳到了澳洲野犬身上，
that the Lapita then took to Southeast Asia. So you get kangaroo fleas in some native gods. So Australia is exporting sex aphrodisiacs and fleas. And fleas. Pretty much. Well, you're really selling it. So, David, you mentioned China. Now, there is a theory, is there not, that the Chinese discovered Australia?
拉皮塔人随后把这些澳洲野犬带到了东南亚。所以你会在某些本土神明身上发现袋鼠跳蚤。因此，澳大利亚当时在出口催情剂和跳蚤。还有跳蚤。差不多吧。好吧，你可真会推销。那么，大卫，你提到了中国。现在有一种说法，不是吗，说是中国人发现了澳大利亚？
What do you make of that? If you're an Australian, it's a disturbing theory because in 2003, Premier Hu Jintao became, I think, just the second non-Australian to address both houses of parliament and basically said, look, we were here in the 1420s engaging in harmonious relations with the locals. Effectively, we were here first. China discovered the world, which basically said these vast treasure fleets had travelled all over the world as far south as Antarctica to the Americas. And two parts of that fleet up the east coast and west coast of Australia in the 1420s. And the idea is that there are these eunuch admirals. David, fans will be so pleased that you've got in some genital mutilation.
你怎么看？如果你是一个澳大利亚人，这是一个令人不安的理论，因为在2003年，时任总理胡锦涛成为我认为第二位在议会两院发表演讲的非澳大利亚人，他基本上说，看，我们在15世纪20年代就在这里与当地人进行和谐的交往。实际上，是我们先来的。中国发现了世界，这基本上是说，这些庞大的宝船曾驶向世界各地，向南远至南极洲，甚至到达美洲。而在15世纪20年代，该船队有两部分分别驶上了澳大利亚的东西海岸。这种说法的核心是，有一些太监海军统帅。大卫，粉丝们一定会很高兴你提到了生殖器切除。
Well, I do have a section of my first book called Chinese Sellers with No Junk. And the suggestion has been roundly ridiculed. Menzies looks at Australian evidence from a chap called Rex Gilroy, who he cites as being some eminent Australian historian.
好吧，我的第一本书里确实有一章叫“没有阉割的中国水手”（Chinese Sellers with No Junk）。而这种说法遭到了普遍的嘲笑。孟席斯（Menzies）参考了一位名叫雷克斯·吉尔罗伊（Rex Gilroy）的人提供的澳大利亚证据，他将此人引为某位杰出的澳大利亚历史学家。
Rex actually wrote for a series of Australian magazines in the 1980s, stories like Why Yowie is a Fair Dinkum, the Yowie being the Australian equivalent of the Bigfoot, our own Nessie, about Stonehenge is here, and is the sort of guy who wrote stories about UFOs in magazines with topless women on the cover. This is presented by Menzies as a reliable primary source. That's on Holland.
雷克斯实际上在20世纪80年代为一系列澳大利亚杂志撰写过文章，比如《为什么毛人是正宗的》（Why Yowie is a Fair Dinkum）这类故事——“毛人”（Yowie）就是澳大利亚版的“大脚怪”，我们自己的尼斯湖水怪——还有诸如“巨石阵在这里”之类的话题，他就是那种在封面印有半裸女性的杂志里撰写UFO故事的人。然而，孟席斯却把这当作可靠的第一手资料呈献出来。这就是关于荷兰的那部分。
And it's been labelled as junk history in various Australian exposés of the reliability of those Australian Chinese companies. So the Chinese didn't come to Australia, basically. There's no compelling evidence that the Chinese did come. They would have certainly known once the Macassans started delivering them dried trepang of the existence of the landmass to the south, but there's no evidence that they themselves came here, no.
在各种揭露那些澳大利亚华人公司的可靠性的澳大利亚曝光节目中，它被贴上了垃圾历史的标签。所以，中国人根本没有来过澳大利亚。没有任何令人信服的证据表明中国人来过。一旦望加锡人开始向他们运送干海参，他们肯定会知道南半球这片陆地的存在，但没有证据表明他们自己曾来到这里，没有。
Because they weren't particularly interested in anything that wasn't China. Well, look, the idea is that there is some evidence of these treasure fleets in the 1420s. Yeah, they went to Africa, didn't they, and brought back giraffes? Yeah, and India, but then there was a policy from the 1430s on of effectively isolation and closing themselves off from the world. So, yeah, no, it's highly speculative at best.
因为他们对任何不是中国的东西都不怎么感兴趣。好吧，你看，这种说法的核心是，有证据表明这些宝船在15世纪20年代存在。是的，他们去过非洲，不是吗，还带回了长颈鹿？是的，还有印度，但随后从15世纪30年代开始，奉行了一种实际上是闭关锁国、将自己与世界隔绝的政策。所以，是的，不，这往好了说也只是高度猜测性的。
And, David, I'm just dredging this up from my memory, so I may have got this wrong. Wasn't there quite recently some Arab coins found on a beach that had come from Africa or something? Look, there are always, yeah, there have been some sort of shell-like coins. There are always bits of old coins and bits of old cannon found on Australian beaches.
而且，大卫，我只是从记忆中搜寻这些内容，所以我可能记错了。最近不是在海滩上发现了一些来自非洲或类似地方的阿拉伯硬币吗？你看，总会有，是的，曾经有过一些类似于贝壳的硬币。在澳大利亚的海滩上总能找到一些旧硬币和大炮的碎片。
Coins, Australia or New South Wales when it was formed was famous for having no currency, a deliberate decision to have no currency where rum becomes the liquid currency of choice. But what you have is you have sailors bringing coins from all over the world that may be, you know, pieces of eight. They what you have is you have sailors bringing coins from all over the world that may be, you know, pieces of eight. They may be quite old. They may have been bought out at some much later time. So, look, before 1606, there's no evidence of any sort of European contact. No compelling evidence of European contact. And then what happens in 1606?
硬币方面，澳大利亚或新南威尔士州在刚成立时，以没有货币而闻名，这是一个刻意决定不设货币的举措，当时朗姆酒成了人们首选的液态货币。但你所看到的是，水手们带来了世界各地的硬币，这些硬币可能是，你知道的，八里亚尔银币。它们你所看到的是，水手们带来了世界各地的硬币，这些硬币可能是，你知道的，八里亚尔银币。它们可能相当古老。它们可能是后来在某个时间点被买进来的。所以，你看，在1606年之前，没有任何证据表明存在任何形式的欧洲接触。没有令人信服的欧洲接触证据。那么1606年发生了什么？
Why is that such a key date? Look, there are two things that happened. The first is that the Dutch East Indies Company is formed in 1602, and they've muscled the Portuguese out of the Spice Islands, bits of Indonesia, to Australia's north. And so they are sending ships over to look for spices, send spices back to the Netherlands and around the world. And William Jan Soen, the captain of the Dufkin,
为什么这是一个如此关键的日子？你看，发生了两件事。首先是荷兰东印度公司在1602年成立，他们将葡萄牙人挤出了位于澳大利亚北部的香料群岛以及印度尼西亚的一部分。因此，他们派遣船只前去寻找香料，将香料运回荷兰并销往世界各地。而“杜夫肯号”（Dufkin）的船长威廉·扬松（William Janzoon），
was sent south from the Spice Islands to look at whether there were new economic opportunities for trade, for collecting spice or other valuable trade goods. And he runs into the Cape York Peninsula in what is now northern Queensland and charts about 300 kilometres of it. He calls it Os Papua, thinks it's part of New Guinea. He names part of New Guinea, New Zealand, and sort of sails off in a state of geographical confusion. But you do have that Dutch contact in 16...
被从香料群岛派往南方，以考察是否存在用于贸易、收集香料或其他有价值贸易商品的新经济机会。他驶入了位于现今昆士兰州北部的约克角半岛（Cape York Peninsula），并绘制了大约300公里的海岸线地图。他将其称为“新巴布亚”（Os Papua），误以为它是新几内亚的一部分。他给新几内亚的一部分命名为新西兰，然后在一种地理迷失的状态下扬帆离去。不过你确实在16...年看到了这种荷兰人的接触。
So when does Tasman turn up? Tasman turns up in 1642. He claims Van Diemen's land. He's a suck-up. He names it after his boss, Anthony Van Diemen, who's higher up in the Dutch East Indies Company. He goes and paddles around New Zealand and names New Zealand New Zealand, comes back and names the Australian landmass New Holland.
那么塔斯曼是什么时候出现的？塔斯曼出现在1642年。他宣称占领了范迪门斯地（Van Diemen's land）。他是个马屁精。他以他的老板安东尼·范·迪门（Anthony Van Diemen）的名字来命名，后者在荷兰东印度公司职位更高。他四处划船环游新西兰，并将新西兰命名为New Zealand，回来后又把澳大利亚大陆命名为新荷兰（New Holland）。
That's a great name. It's a great shame that it changed. The Dutch previously knew Australia as Beach before they called it New Holland. Beach. That's wonderful. Full of sand. Yeah. And when did they discover the quokka?
那是个伟大的名字。改了名实在太遗憾了。荷兰人在将其命名为新荷兰之前，以前称澳大利亚为“比奇”（Beach）。比奇。太棒了。到处都是沙子。是的。他们是什么时候发现短尾矮袋鼠的呢？
The quokka? Well, the quokka lives on Rottnest Island and would have been discovered fairly – just off the coast of Perth. For those of you who don't know the quokka, it is not megafauna. It is a small, cuddly, smiley kangaroo, much loved by tourists and much loved by starving Dutch sailors who stopped off at the island and ate it. So why don't the Dutch – so, okay, why isn't Australia Dutch? Okay, and also, Dominic, we've got a question here
短尾矮袋鼠？嗯，短尾矮袋鼠生活在罗特尼斯岛（Rottnest Island）上，应该是在离珀斯海岸不远的地方被发现的——相当容易。对于那些不认识短尾矮袋鼠的人来说，它并不是巨型动物。它是一只娇小、可爱、带着微笑的袋鼠，深受游客喜爱，也深受那些在岛上停留并吃掉它们的饥饿的荷兰水手们的喜爱。那么为什么荷兰人——好吧，为什么澳大利亚不是荷兰的呢？好吧，还有，多米尼克，我们这里有一个问题，
from Eric Mercer. References to New Holland aside, was there any real possibility of the Dutch or indeed the French colonising Australia? Or was it always going to be England driven by its loss of the American colonies? Well, that's the question, isn't it? I mean, why on earth don't people,
来自埃里克·默瑟（Eric Mercer）。抛开对新荷兰的提及不谈，荷兰人或法国人是否有任何真正殖民澳大利亚的可能性？还是说，这注定只能是由失去美洲殖民地的英国来主导？嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗？我的意思是，为什么人们，
if they've got their first, or indeed the Portuguese, they're in place, why on earth is, are they not all speaking, you know, Dutch or Portuguese in Australia? Well, look, I mean, as I say, the Portuguese theory of the sort of there in the 1520s on the East Coast is heavily contested. Those who insist that it is true, insist that as a result of the Treaty of Torsadilla, I think in 1494, where Spain and Portugal divide the world between themselves and the Pope says, you have this bit, you have that bit, that the Portuguese were in the wrong place
如果他们先到达那里，或者甚至是葡萄牙人，他们已经在那里了，为什么澳大利亚人不说，你知道的，荷兰语或葡萄牙语呢？好吧，你看，我的意思是，正如我所说，关于葡萄牙人在15世纪20年代左右出现在东海岸的理论受到了激烈的争论。那些坚信这是真的的人坚持认为，由于1494年的《托尔德西利亚斯条约》（大概是这个时间），当时西班牙和葡萄牙瓜分了世界，教皇说“这一块归你，那一块归你”，由于这个原因，葡萄牙人出现在了错误的地方，
and so were shy about writing their discovery down, or that all the records burnt in a fire in a library in Lisbon. No evidence of this. The Spanish would have colonised Australia and 1606 is an important year because Louis Vas de Torres sails through the Torres Strait, the body of water that separates Australia from New Guinea,
所以他们对把自己的发现写下来感到羞羞答答，或者说所有的记录都在里斯本某座图书馆的一场火灾中被烧毁了。没有任何证据表明这一点。西班牙本可以殖民澳大利亚，而1606年是一个重要的年份，因为路易斯·瓦斯·德·托雷斯（Louis Vas de Torres）驶过了托雷斯海峡（Torres Strait）——这片将澳大利亚与新几内亚隔开的水域——
and actually saw most probably the northernmost tip of Australia thinking it was another island in this sort of sea of treacherous shoals that he desperately wanted to get out of. He didn't stop. But if he had, the Spanish would have taken an interest because they were into colonizing. They were interested in spreading Christianity. They were interested in finding Terra Australis incognita. And it's lucky for the Brits that they kept on sailing.
并且极有可能看到了澳大利亚的最北端，以为它是他迫切想要逃离的那片充满危险暗礁的海域中的又一个岛屿。他没有停留。但如果他停下来了，西班牙人就会产生兴趣，因为他们热衷于殖民。他们对传播基督教感兴趣。他们对寻找“未知的南方大陆”（Terra Australis incognita）感兴趣。英国人能一直航行下去，真算是走运了。
The Dutch were a mercantile people. And if there was nothing, the East Indies Company was a mercantile company. It was sort of a projection of Dutch power, but it operated independently of the government. And it was only interested in setting up trading posts where there was something to buy or sell. And they decided that the bits of Australia that they stopped off at had called Dirk Hartog, who nails a pewter plate to a post which basically says Dirk Hartog was here, which was the Dutch way of sort of saying we're here.
荷兰人是一个商业民族。如果没有什么东西，东印度公司就是一个商业公司。它有点像荷兰权力的投射，但它独立于政府运作。它只对在有东西可买卖的地方建立贸易站感兴趣。他们认为他们停靠的澳大利亚那些地方——德克·哈托格（Dirk Hartog）曾在一个柱子上钉了一块锡铅合金牌，上面基本上写着“德克·哈托格到此一游”，这就是荷兰人宣示“我们在这里”的方式。
The French, when they came, left bottles lying around bits of the Australian coast with messages in them, you know. I, Marion de Frasnay was here. The French come to and sail up the coast of Western Australia in 1687. A bloke called Abraham du Quesnay-Guiton cites the Swan River but keeps on sailing for the Spice Islands to the north. The French weren't terribly interested in colonisation at the time. They were interested in trade and sort of scientific discovery.
法国人来的时候，在澳大利亚海岸的一些地方留下了带有瓶中信的瓶子，你知道的。我，马里恩·迪·弗拉奈（Marion de Frasnay）曾到此一游。法国人于1687年来到西澳大利亚海岸并沿岸航行。一个叫亚伯拉罕·迪克凯纳-吉通（Abraham du Quesnay-Guiton）的家伙注意到了天鹅河（Swan River），但继续向北驶往香料群岛。当时法国人对殖民并不是非常感兴趣。他们对贸易和某种科学发现感兴趣。
So the Spanish would have taken a more active interest if they'd stopped off. French and Dutch, not so much. And even the Brits, when Cook arrives in 1770, Joseph Banks, you know, the scientific go-to guy aboard the Endeavour. He's a botanist who gives the name Botanist. He's a botanist who is the inspiration for Mr Spock in Star Trek. He and James Cook was the inspiration for James Kirk. Star Trek was modelled on the Endeavour voyage.
所以如果西班牙人停下来，他们会对这里产生更浓厚的兴趣。法国人和荷兰人则不然。甚至连英国人在1770年库克船长抵达时也是如此，约瑟夫·班克斯（Joseph Banks），你知道的，“决心号”（Endeavour）上的科学核心人物。他是一位植物学家，正是他赋予了植物学之名。他是一位植物学家，也是《星际迷航》中史波克先生（Mr Spock）的灵感来源。他和詹姆斯·库克一起成为了詹姆斯·柯克（James Kirk）的灵感来源。《星际迷航》就是以“决心号”的航行为蓝本创作的。
But Banks says the country reminded him of the back of a lean cow and his sort of scathing of its suitability for settlement. Until 1878 when he has a change of heart, the American War of Independence, Britain's desperately looking for somewhere new to dump its convicts and Banks says, well, this place wasn't so bad. But you still have a period of 10 years where the Brits look at the idea of convict settlements in East Africa, the West Indies. They again try to send some convicts
但班克斯说这个国家让他想起了瘦弱母牛的背部，他对这里是否适合定居进行了尖锐的批判。直到1787年他才改变看法，当时美国独立战争爆发，英国急切地寻找新的地方来倾倒罪犯，于是班克斯说，嗯，这个地方其实没那么糟。但你仍然有长达10年的时间，英国人考虑在东非、西印度群岛建立罪犯定居点的想法。他们再次试图把一些罪犯送到
to the Americas, the Mosquito Coast. New South Wales was very much an afterthought and it appealed to the Brits not so much because of anything that Cook or Banks said, but it was so geographically isolated. There was no other Western settlement about. And when you sent your convicts to America, they kept on popping on boats and coming home. The idea was that if you dumped convicts in Botany Bay,
美洲，送到蚊子海岸（Mosquito Coast）。新南威尔士州在很大程度上是一个事后才想到的主意，它吸引英国人的地方与其说是库克或班克斯说了什么，不如说是它在地理上是如此孤立。周围没有其他西方定居点。而当你把罪犯送到美洲时，他们总是不断地跳上船回家。当时的设想是，如果你把罪犯倾倒在植物湾（Botany Bay）——
which rapidly moved to Sydney, they wouldn't be able to get back. And so that ended up being... Except Magwitch. Magwitch does come back. Yeah. Well, look, the irony is that the first convicts actually escaped within a couple of weeks aboard French vessels. Peter Paris, a French waiter, hitched a ride off, yeah, from La Perouse.
这里很快就迁移到了悉尼——他们就无法回来了。所以最终的结果是……除了玛吉奇（Magwitch）。玛吉奇确实回来了。是的。嗯，你看，具有讽刺意味的是，第一批罪犯其实在几周内就搭乘法国船只逃跑了。彼得·帕里斯（Peter Paris），一名法国侍者，搭便车离开了，是的，从拉彼鲁兹（La Perouse）那里。
So they went off to France, did they? Well, the La Perouse expedition pops up in Botany Bay just a few days after Philip arrives in 1788, and there's this, geez, the French are here, and there's lots of them. They camp in Botany Bay for a while, and two of the convicts, or lots of the convicts run from Sydney to Botany Bay and hold up their little hitchhiking sides, please take us home. Two of them escape and the La Perouse expedition probably founded off the Solomon Islands and most of them
所以他们去了法国，是吗？嗯，拉彼鲁兹探险队在1788年菲利普（Philip）抵达几天后突然出现在植物湾，当时的情形是：天哪，法国人来了，而且有那么多人。他们在植物湾扎营了一段时间，其中两名罪犯，或者说很多罪犯从悉尼跑到植物湾，举起他们的小“搭便车”牌子，请把我们带回家。其中两人逃跑了，而拉彼鲁兹探险队可能在所罗门群岛附近沉没，他们大多数人都
were eaten. But eaten? Yes, the Solomon Islanders liked French food. Oh, my God. And so, David, Australia begins. Indeed. So hopefully we could continue this story. We should definitely continue this story. We should definitely do a part two. Yes, so if you were willing to come back that would be that would be fantastic do uh no look i'd i'd love to talk with you about the founding of the wonderful convict colony of new south wales yeah if we can take the story then from that to ian botham then everybody will be happy
被吃掉了。被吃掉了？是的，所罗门群岛人喜欢法国菜。噢，天哪。所以，大卫，澳大利亚的故事开始了。确实如此。所以希望我们能继续这个故事。我们绝对应该继续这个故事。我们绝对应该做第二部分。是的，如果你愿意回来的话，那将是——那将非常棒，做呃——不，看，我——我很乐意和你一起聊聊新南威尔士州这个美妙的罪犯殖民地的建立，是的，如果我们能把故事从那个时候讲到伊恩·博瑟姆（Ian Botham），那么每个人都会开心的。
i i think that we should um wait until uh this uh next ashes series is over before indulging in too much sport related banter because I'm slightly nervous because we remember what happened when the last Captain Cook, Alistair Cook came to Australia and it wasn't it was well it was they basically got eaten I do
我——我认为我们应该——呃，等到——呃，这下一场灰烬杯（Ashes）系列赛结束后，再沉溺于太多与体育相关的调侃，因为我有点紧张，因为我们还记得上次库克船长、阿拉斯泰尔·库克（Alistair Cook）来到澳大利亚时发生了什么，那感觉可不太好，好吧，他们基本上被吃掉了。我确实
have several cricket stories in my books. That's part of the rich tapestry of British Australian history. I can't wait. I can't wait. David, thanks so much for that. That was absolutely fabulous.
在我的书里写了好几个板球故事。那是英国-澳大利亚历史丰富挂毯的一部分。我等不及了。我等不及了。大卫，太谢谢你了。那真是太棒了。
And hopefully we'll speak to you soon. Thank you very much, Tom. Thanks, Dominic. All right. Thank you, David. Bye, everybody. See you next time. Good day. everybody see you next time good day thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus
希望我们很快能再与你交谈。非常感谢，汤姆。谢谢你，多米尼克。好的。谢谢你，大卫。大家再见。下次见。再见。大家再见，下次见，再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History），要想获得更多精彩内容、
episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
独家抢先收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 订阅。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。